with you we talked about last week who
we
wanted to see in here and and the
consideration we were hoping like i was
hoping dejante murray would get he's
having an unbelievable year with the
spurs who record wise have really
struggled but your thoughts on him
well i i actually expected their record
to be even worse uh than than what it
actually is and i think
it hasn't been that in large part due to
de johnson's play he's continued to grow
each and every year you're talking a kid
who had an acl injury rehab came back
stronger and if you follow dejante at
all the kid lives in the gym so
hopefully he'll get rewarded one of
these days soon
i think
he may have a chance to get rewarded
because i won't be able to play in the
all-star game so
he may have a chance to get rewarded um
by commissioner silver and i hope that
comes to fruition for him because he
deserves it 20 points a night eight
rebounds nine assists he's fourth in
assists he's got ten triple doubles he's
the league leader in steels uh but you
make an excellent point draymond and
thank you for also for the uh
for the insight into when you may be
coming back i know it's going to be
after the all-star break yeah i mean
also you know another guy that's going
to be under heavy consideration is jaron
jackson
uh you know
memphis grizzlies are on a tear he's
playing great basketball you know john
moran is obviously playing mvp caliber
but that team when he was out played
just as well at times so uh jaren
jackson is going to be we're good
when we picked our our reserves last
week i had jared jackson on my list he's
been fabulous all year i mean
obviously josh is the man but i think
jackson is really
when he's he's
been a really nice number two he's the
second and this is the unfortunate part
of the business you can only pick seven
reserves so every year is always going
to be somebody that's very very close to
getting in but you know
wish him well for next year did we have
the uh
a look at
the guys that we
thought would be reserves in the western
conference
from last week and we'll see how we how
we did in
this
well you and i both had karl anthony
towns and so oh do we run the table on
that
shaq and myself we always do brother
since 1989 brother
i wouldn't be mad to see the spartan dog
get in there i wouldn't be mad at that
at all
all right so uh so those seven
um hey draymond in your days
of this
who have you seen taking this the
hardest when they have not made it one
thing i can assure you if i didn't make
it this year i wasn't going to cry
100 assure you that
um
it has to be rudy i mean the man cried
on national television when he didn't
make the all-star team thank god he's
made the next three yeah
stop it dre leave that man alone i mean
you can't cry chuck i said it then i'm
gonna say it now i got killed on twitter
then i'll probably get killed today but
you can't cry
come on come on man something he's
friends he's sensitive
all-star reserves representing the
phoenix suns in game one of our
doubleheader the suns and the hawks
chris paul is in there as is
devin booker third time he's made the
all-star team
for the 41-9
phoenix suns